Doutor, própolis verde pode aumentar a
liberação de estamina em quem é
intolerante? Boa pergunta. Toda vez que
uso, pior. É porque sim, provavelmente
você tem intolerância a estamina. O
própolis verde é uma substância natural
das abelhas, tem propiedades
antiinflamatórias, imunomoduladoras, é
maravilhoso na grande maioria dos casos,
mas pode sim desencadear, agravar
problemas, sintomas em pessoas com
intolerância estamina. Isso acontece por
quê? Porque o própolis ele contém
compostos, né? Vários compostos, alguns
são maravilhosos paraa saúde, porém tem
os talos caféartes e flavonoides. Quem
pessoas sensíveis pode estimular a
liberação de estamina pelos mastósicos
são as células de defesa. Isso vai
piorar sintomas como coceira,
vermelhidão, congestão nasal, enxaqueca,
desconforto
gastrointestinal, poptação, até um monte
de sintoma. Além disso, tem relatos que
o próprio Luiz Verde pode cruzar, fazer
reações cruzadas alérgicas com outras
substâncias, como é o caso do bálsamo do
Peru, que tá presente em alguns produtos
naturais ou mesmo em cosméticos. Então,
para quem já tem deficiência na enzima
DAL, então você só vai saber se tem
deficiência dessa enzima fazendo exame,
infelizmente. Que que a DAL? É de
aminooxidase. É uma enzima responsável
por degradar estamina e outras aminas
semelhantes, como cadaverina.
que vão dar a estimulação dos
mastócitos. Então, uso de própolis verde
pode sobrecarregar esse sistema, já que
a estamina não é metabolizada de forma
adequada e vai se acumular no organismo,
especialmente no intestino. Então, no
seu caso, você tem que parar o o
própolis, porque, infelizmente, você tem
que cuidar primeiro desse problema da
estamina, parar os outros derivados de
abelha, priorizar uma dieta pobre em
alimentos ricos em estamina, então fazer
uma dieta baixa em estamina, cortando
embutidos, cortando queijo maturado,
cortando o álcool, cortando os alimentos
que foram guardados em geladeira.
incluir suplementos de dal de aminoxe.
Tem adidal e tem o nutrodal. Tem a fonte
vegetal e a fonte animal dessas enzimas
que podem ser necessárias no seu caso,
obviamente depois de fazer uma avaliação
médica e nutricional, OK? O D vai ajudar
a quebrar esse excesso de estamina se
você tiver excesso no intestino. Então
uso também de quecetina, que é um
flavonoide com ação
antialérgica. Tá presente em cebolas e
maçãs, a vitamina C junto com
aquecetina, que a vitamina C é um
antihistamico natural, probióticos
específicos, vão melhorar a saúde
intestinal, vão melhorar essa
intolerância estamina, 80% da dalda de
aminoxidase é produzido no intestino,
OK? Em casos persistentes, é muito
importante investigar a disbiose com
comprológico estendido, um exame
compromax ou exame de sensibilidades
alimentares também podem ser importantes
que possam estar contribuindo pro seu
problema. Então, sempre consulte um
médico, entenda disso ou nutricionista,
de preferência os dois para ajustes
personalizados. Boa sorte no seu
caminho. Ja.